sport il football avec cet événement
guyancourt qui pourrait réaliser un
exploit ce week end anthony rech vous
allez tout nous expliquer bonsoir
bonsoir wilfried oui c'est le fameux 64e
de finale de coupe gambardella la coupe
des moins de 19 ans qui va opposer donc
le fbi en cours l'étoile sportive de
guyancourt les jeunes face aux grands aj
auxerre de guy roux et pour en parler ce
soir avec nous deux représentants du
club guy gallant ti et pierre ribot vous
êtes respect respectivement directeur
technique du club et est président de
l'ess lioncourt bon soir bonsoir
alors nous sommes à j - 84 jours un de
ce fameux événements de ce fameux match
historique à la pression sans qui
montrent un petit peu un j'étais au bord
du terrain hier soir avec les jeunes
mais avant de parler à proprement parler
de votre travail du travail de
l'encadrement du club pour pour cet
événement je propose de voir la
préparation des joueurs d'olivier jean
vresse nous étions présents hier soir à
l'entraînement des u19 avec patrick
jacques de dixmude ce 64e de finale
pourrait être le match de leur vie
depuis le tirage au sort mi décembre le
choc face à l'aj auxerre est dans toutes
les têtes
joueurs entraîneurs de le fbi en cours
ont du mal à rester en place
mais pas question de changer les
habitudes à l'entraînement ce soir là au
programme ateliers de vivacité et
conservation de balle comme tous les
mardis on sait qu'on fait du foncier de
mardi avec un petit peu de jeux de
ballons demain soir on fait un petit
match amical et jeudi comme d'habitude
ça sera plus de jeux de ballons avec les
gardiens et tout ça mais on change rend
pas plus que ça l'habitude que des
entraînements auxerre n'est autre que le
champion de france en titre de la
catégorie tout simplement ce qui se fait
de mieux dans l'hexagone
mais ce palmarès n'impressionne pas les
jeunes saint quentinois ils feront tout
pour vaincre l'ogre bourguignon est
imité finale en coupe de france
tombeurs de l'olympique lyonnais il ya
quelques jours ça me donne beaucoup
d'idées franchement quand je vois ces
clubs là c'est beau pour le foot on va
dire puisque c'est rare que des clubs
comme ça ils arrivent à s'imposer face à
des gros clubs
donc non
ouais c'est une chose créé la surprise
pour moi ouais ils ont des jambes et
deux bras comme nous voilà on est plus
motivé que jamais alors vraiment classe
et je pense c'est comme un rêve pour
nous tous on est heureux
oui si on peut aller plus loin royal et
on va tout faire pour
lors des quatre premiers tours
l'entraîneur n'avait pas anticipé la
séance de tirs au but
un moment crucial où jordan doussain
gardien de but de le sg sera plus que
jamais le dernier rempart c'est un
exercice que j'aime bien mais si on
pouvait ne pas y arriver ça serait mieux
mais s'ils allaient penalty aura les
penaltys en phr avec bien des techniques
mais bon souvent c'est l'instinct pour
la plupart les jeunes guyancourt toi
ajoute ensemble depuis cinq voire six
saisons plus que onze joueurs c'est une
bande de copains qui voudra à tout prix
continuer l aventure
alors on sent un que les u19 lasson sont
dans les starting blocks 1 ils sont
prêts à en découdre mais alors du côté
des dirigeants quel est l'état d'esprit
aussi impatient excité à l'idée de ce
match historique pour le club président
qui peu moins que les joueurs
certainement mais bon effectivement pour
le club ses c'est un match important
puisque c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire du club
nos jeunes arrivent à ce niveau là en
coupe gambardella donc bien sûr il ya un
petit peu de noms pas d'appréhension de
joie aussi enfin surtout de joie au
départ pour pour organiser ce match
contre une équipe et un club qui est
renommé dans toute la france et au delà
des frontières aussi
donc non il n'y a pas de pression
particulière mais on est attentif un
petit peu a peut-être plus de choses que
d'habitude mais c'est un objectif du
président en début de saison on
atteindre ce niveau c'est un bonus un
petit peu oui c'est un bonus tout à fait
l'écart avec auxerre en rougir archi et
la cinq divisions d'écart entre les deux
clubs donc négatif
l'objectif c'est toujours de gagner le
prochain match donc on verra bien
dimanche soir et du côté du directeur
technique puisque vous guide vous avez
renforcer un petit peu le staff pour se
voir vous avez vous avez un peu
accompagne et vous accompagnez olivier
sur 7 sur cette préparation de rencontre
vous les sentez comment si vous êtes un
peu plus près des joueurs on va dire oui
oui bien entendu mais c'est je crois au
niveau 2 du club en tout cas il ya une
politique technique qui a été mis en
place
c'est c'est une surprise mais ce n'est
pas une parce que ce groupe là on a tout
fait pour conserver toutes nos équipes
sont pratiquement en ligue souffle des
u19 mais on connaissait la qualité de
ses joueurs et c'est une surprise mais
ça n'est pas vraiment une parce que on a
le sentiment que ce groupe là en tout
cas évoluerez tranquillement en
régionale et pour ça notre commission
technique avec les éducateurs qu'on a et
qui sont pu l'entendre dans notre giron
dans le club je pense à yannick jude
qu'ont beaucoup participer à ce groupe
là je pense notamment à eux je pense que
le groupe
il est assez solide bon ça va être très
difficile mais il ya la motivation
et puis j'espère que bon il faut avoir
un brin de chance et ce sont des joueurs
qui sont là depuis longtemps
oui oui 2 avait vraiment des années
pendant l'intersaison
non non non non bien au contraire en or
souhaitée en garde et deux 2 autres mais
bon ils étaient très sollicités pour
l'heure du club pour l'instant pourquoi
qui pour la plupart ils se connaissent
depuis 5 6 ans connaissent depuis les
8-13 alors les u15 pour les
retardataires mais bien avant pour sa
cohésion qui fait leur force mais d'être
aussi depuis le début' depuis les
débutants
quelques-uns et ça marche cette cohésion
voilà et le club se construit grâce à
eux
et alors justement le club à vous en
parlait il ya une organisation
particulière sur ce match j'étais il ya
quelques jours aussi à la réunion du
comité technique au niveau sécurité
j'imagine qu'un qu'un 64e de coupe
gambardella ça se prépare pas comme ça
vous lui a préparé un petit peu
spécialement quand même cet événement
parce que effectivement ça peut poser
des problèmes les sacs posera sûrement
aucun problème j'espère mais ça peut il
faut réfléchir un petit peu à la
sécurité toute l'organisation
donc ça se fait pas comme ça en claquant
dans les doigts donc on s'est réuni on a
prévu un petit peu la faire depuis un
certain temps depuis qu'on sait qu'on
joue contre auxerre du moins tout le
club est mobilisé du coup alors les
parents de joueurs j'imagine qu'ils vont
peut-être être à la bêta de dimanche non
les éducateurs ramasseurs de balle et
c'est absolument les sa radio pour le
club
pardon ça a un coût pour le club ceci
parce qu'il fabrique moi vous pour le
club
il faut savoir qu'en coupe gambardella
il ya une une caisse de péréquation qui
permet au club qui se déplacent d'avoir
des indemnités et les clubs qui
reçoivent paye un petit peu pour ce qui
est des places savez vous avez vous
content de recevoir
on veut bien encore recevoir le prochain
tour et alors est ce que vous avez un
pronostic sur ce match
quand je pense je discutais avec avec
jordan le gardien de but hier il me 0,2
avant le temps à la fin du temps
réglementaire ce sera de 1 je pense
qu'on va y arriver après les 90 minutes
non pour avoir connu quelques épisodes
dans ma jeunesse jamais de pronostic sur
ce type de match ça peut être très
sanglant ou alors l'exploit et alors il
va y avoir un une tactique particulière
on va pas tout dévoiler un des français
les gens cessent jamais de u19 il
rappelle ainsi les champions de france
en titre de la catégorie
on va peut-être essayer d'être un peu
plus la surface de réparation la bombe
anti dévoiler des certainement alors
après passable en tout cas cette coupe
c'est un véritable plus vous nous l'avez
dit en football qu'apportent ces coupes
nationales aux petits clubs c est une
question que nous sommes allez vous
poser puis vous pourrez nous dira si
c'est un vrai plus ou si vous la
subissez malgré tout un petit peu cette
coupe peut leur apporter une assurance
déjà de se sentir bon de pouvoir évoluer
mettez dans les grades ça leur apporte
un peu de notoriété pour commencer un
peu d'argent pour les petits clubs
l'occasion se met en avant est
l'occasion de rencontrer des clubs plus
importants que situe au dessus de 2 dans
la hiérarchie
donc c'est très positif de l'argent oui
non juste pour le plaisir de gagner quoi
la salle pour pouvoir jouer contre des
équipes plus fortes avec un meilleur
niveau
et puis ça rapporte aussi de l'argent
pour les clubs c'est ils ont besoin
surtout les plus petits
cette revue dans le milieu sportif de
faire là les populations locales s'en
rendre compte qu'elle soit un club
sportif et qu'il faudrait peut être les
soutenir
donc ça apporte de la notoriété ça c'est
sûr parce que ça rapporte de l'argent la
première réponse et de l'argent c'est un
mythe on verra si on a beaucoup de
public que l'on espère se nouera portera
peut-être un petit peu d'argent mais le
but il est pas là le but il est vraiment
que les joueurs jouent leur jeu déjà et
puis et puis et puis ce sera de toute
façon une expérience inoubliable qu'on
met en colère guy roux ça sera bien
aussi
et si on a le bonheur de trouver des
sponsors les gens nous on les brûle des
brisants pourquoi pas lundi avec un gain
de la supporter les u19 de l'ulg ces
rendez-vous keller dimanche alors
attendre jallieu 14h30 au stade maurice
baquet et l'on attend le plus de monde
possible grâce bien sûr l'événement sur
tenais tout à fait un wilfried pour ce
match historique 1 le service port de tv
fils se mobilisent dans le prochain 7,8
sport vous pourrez découvrir le film
complet de ces 64e de finale entre le
est lui encore l aj auxerre avec des
images exclusives au coeur de l'équipe
d'olivier jaurès merci entonné on
retrouve lundi donc pour 7,8 sport merci
à vous deux est bonne ce match que faire
à présente vos sapins de noël ça n'a
rien à voir avec le football plusieurs
communes propose une aide au recyclage
comme à montigny le bretonneux
vous pouvez y déposer vos sapins dans
des sites de collecte ils sont ensuite
broyés et réutilisées par les services
les espaces verts voilà comment cela
fonctionne regardez c'est la grande
nouveauté de montigny le bretonneux
cette année pour la première fois les
inimités peuvent déposer leur sapin dans
l'un des dix centres de la ville pour
les recycler les sympas sont transformés
en paillage sur chaque point de dépôt
par une broyeuse
c'est paillage des différentes collectes
sont réutilisés par la direction
environnement des espaces verts pour
remplir le manque de végétation des
seuls depuis le 2 janvier
le ramassage a lieu une fois par semaine
le but de la collecte et de limiter le
nombre de déchets dans la ville une
quarantaine de sapins et collecter puis
broyés pendant environ 30 minutes
le broyage commence après la coupe des
bus sur chaque site
on ramasse en fait seulement les sapins
verts donc les épicéas les habillait
sans fin donc les sapins de noël et les
les nordmann les pour les plus courants
mais sans décoration sans bûche sans sac
à sapin
éventuellement on est venu en relève
aussi les sapins floqués sauf floqué
givrés qui pour l'instant la technique
ne permet pas de les mettre
stage ou en déchetterie pour tous les
intéressés la collecte des sapins c'est
jusqu'au 14 janvier dans tous les sites
mise à disposition pour l'occasion